What happens when the mysterious machinations of
the Clockworks meet the humble tuna fish sandwich?
Five ordinary tuna sandwiches on white
bread were prepared for testing. The
first sandwich was input on the setting
“Rough,” and produced a pile of wheat,
a pile of yeast, a puddle of water, and a
bloody, twitching segment of tuna muscle.
The second sandwich went through the machinery on
the setting “coarse,” and produced a small loaf
of bread, and several chunks of cooked tuna.
The next sandwich was placed in the machine
on the setting 1:1, and produced a salmon
sandwich on rye bread, which a research
assistant promptly ate and described as “okay.”
The next sandwich, input on the setting “Fine,”
came out the other side as another tuna
sandwich. This time, however, the quality of
both the tuna and the bread had significantly
improved, as well as its nutrient content.
The final sandwich was run through the
machine on the setting “Very fine.”
The output was a small loaf of bread, baked
in the shape of a hyper-realistic tuna fish.
When the door was opened, the bread began
to move as if swimming about the room.
The fish loaf has escaped custody,
and is missing, presumed eaten.